pues sin duda habrá cambios esto es
absolutamente histórico en una lección
que fue histórica en muchos sentidos y
los resultados no dejan de ser
sorprendentes sobre todo cuando ha
habido muchas preocupaciones y mucha
inquietud el tema de la participación
que fue menor a la esperada
al final sufragaron más de 6 millones de
chilenos lo que es un 41% de los casi 15
millones que estaban llamados a las
urnas y es 10 puntos más bajo que los 50
el 51 por ciento que había sufragado
para el plebiscito del pasado 25 de
octubre sin embargo la composición de la
convención constituyente va contra todos
los pronósticos y contra todos los
vaticinios de los distintos analistas
que siempre habían estimado que el hecho
de que la derecha apareciera unida en la
coalición de gobierno apareció unida
incluso con la extrema derecha que
ejemplifica el partido de josé antonio
kast en una sola lista y en un sistema
electoral que utiliza el método de un
que favorece las listas y los partidos
era muy difícil que los independientes
obtuvieran la representación que
así que es una sorpresa en muchos
sentidos la composición de esta
convención constituyente donde la
centroizquierda y la izquierda más
extrema está presente y lo que obligará
a tener que realizar acuerdos porque
ninguna de las fuerzas tiene más de un
tercio por lo tanto es necesario sí o sí
que todos alcancen acuerdos